Your husband's here
to see you.
What happened?
I mean, how did I get here?
Jennifer,
you were in an accident,
and you hit your head.
You don't remember me,
do you?
I don't even know your name.
I'm Russell.
It's really nice to meet you.
This is really our house?
It's been in the family
for a while.
-It's so quiet.
-Better be.
Nearest neighbors are
over a mile away.
Only a mile?
This is Detective Page.
I was wondering if your wife
would come to the station
tomorrow at 11:00
to talk about the accident.
What's tomorrow at 11:00?
I overheard you
outside on the phone.
That was work calling.
They're wondering
when I was coming back.
Russell?
There's someone
in the backyard!
I think I'm gonna head
into town today.
-You gonna be okay?
-I'll be fine.
I feel like just need to take
a look around.
Maybe something
will trigger my memory.
Don't overdo it.
Since Jennifer had no ID,
how did Russell prove
he was her husband?
It says here that he showed
some family photos...
Jennifer and Russell?
That's the happy couple there.
If that's Russell...
who's that?
What did you do
to my husband?
This was no accident.
All I have ever wanted
was for you to love me.